JEREMY STERN:
Greetings and welcome.
My name is Jeremy Stern,
with Google Fiber.
And on August 24, 2015, the
Google Doodle for the day
honored the 125th birthday of
the great Duke Kahanamoku--
a five-time Olympic
Medalist in swimming,
and the father of
modern surfing.
No American athlete
has influenced
two sports has profoundly
as Kahanamoku did.
And yet, he remains an enigmatic
and under-appreciated figure.
Our guest today will share his
deep insights and expertise
on the life and times of Duke
Kahanamoku, a true waterman.
I'm delighted to
introduce to Google
noted author and
writer, David Davis.
David, an Angeleno, has
published several books.
And his works have been
published and appeared
in "The Los Angeles Times,"
"The New York Times," "The Wall
Street Journal,"
"Sports Illustrated,"
and many other
illustrious publications.
A couple administrate
matters-- of course,
we're taping this for "Talks
at Google," a site on YouTube.
And there will be time
for questions at the end.
And because we're
taping, please make sure
that you use the microphone to
ask your questions so that we
capture your questions
for the video audience.
David, welcome to
Google, Los Angeles.
DAVID DAVIS: Thank you so much.
Thanks, Jeremy.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID DAVIS: Welcome, everybody.
Thanks for having me.
Enjoy your lunch while we
talk a little bit about Duke.
And just to preface this, partly
why I embarked on this project
starting in 2011 is
there really hadn't
been-- that I had seen-- a
comprehensive biography of Duke
Kahanamoku.
And it was one of those
sort of mysteries,
as why hasn't there been,
because of his enormous impact
and legacy?
So the interesting thing was the
more research I did, the more I
uncovered that he was
sort of bigger than life,
maybe even than I imagined.
So what I'd like to do today
with you is, in a sense,
give you a little
overview of his life.
And what's sort
of interesting is
that his life-- beyond just
the sports angle, which
is, of course, an important part
of the book and the research--
really parallels modern Hawaii.
And really, starting from his
from his birth, from his roots.
And he is full-blooded Hawaiian.
This is his father,
Duke Kahanamoku Sr,
Who was, as you can see,
part of the Honolulu Police
Department at that time.
And interesting note, one of
his colleagues at the time
was the real-life model for
Charlie Chan, the detective.
Who, of course, was
made into several films.
But he was a Sergeant,
Duke Kahanamoku.
Everybody at the time-- 1890,
when Duke is born-- Hawaii's
a monarchy.
It's an independent nation
run by Queen Liliuokalani.
And there was sort of a mystery
about Duke's first name.
A lot of people thought oh, he's
got to be royalty or related.
And actually, Hawaii
royal bloodlines
are quite complicated.
He wasn't a direct lineage.
But his name really just
came from his father,
which was Duke.
And this is his mother, Julia.
And it's really her family, the
Paoa family-- P-A-O-A-- that,
in a sense, Duke takes
his Waterman roots from.
The Paoa family were quite
influential as waterman.
And I use that term
specifically in Hawaii
and Honolulu, Waikiki.
Waterman is really
an honorific title.
It's a very important
part of the culture.
Of course, of Hawaii being
such an isolated island chain
and especially
wasn't even sort of
"discovered" until
very late in the game.
And so to be a waterman, I mean,
that means you how to paddle.
You know how to sail.
You know where the
fishing holes are.
You know the tides, the wind.
It's a very important aspect.
And Duke, in a sense, takes
his roots, his waterman roots,
from the Paoa family.
And the other thing
that they took,
in a sense-- his
mother's family--
they had a plot of
land in Waikiki.
And 1893, when
Hawaii's monarchy gets
toppled-- of course, America
having a huge influence
and stake in this-- the
family retreats to Waikiki.
And Duke is raised
in Waikiki and spends
much of his formative
years in Waikiki,
which people know today, all
the tourist, hotels, et cetera.
But back then, my gosh,
it was so isolated.
And it was freshwater streams
coming down from the mountains.
There were taro patches, rice
paddies, that sort of thing.
It was this sort of idyllic
water festival of life.
And if you were born
and raised there
you just ran into the ocean.
That was part of
your upbringing,
part of what you did.
This is really the first example
we have of Duke playing sports.
He went to the
Kamehameha schools.
Frankly, they're very
prestigious in this day
and age.
But at the time, were
really trade schools
for native Hawaiians.
And it was part of the effort
to inculcate religion and speak
English language only,
that sort of thing.
And if I can make this work
you can see Duke, of course,
in the back-- I'm not sure I can
make this work-- on the soccer
team.
Let me see.
Can I make it?
Yeah.
And this is the
Kamehameha schools.
And he was quite a
good soccer player.
But his forte, his efforts
would really come via the water.
And this is an early shot
of Duke and his surfboard.
And as you can see, these
are enormous planks of wood.
And for those of you who
know surfing history, surf
historians, back
then the surfboards
were basically 100, 125-pound
planks of wood-- Koa
or Redwood, 12-foot,
16-feet long.
It was a very different style
of surfing than today, which
are the foam boards and
shorter and very maneuverable
with fins and that
sort of thing.
These, one commentator
called them
coffin lids as a description.
And that's basically
what they were.
But I will point out-- and
you'll see some photos of Duke
a little bit later without his
top-- it seems to me that this
is, in a sense, the
first instance or one
of the first instances
of cross training.
Because he had to lug that
board through the sand.
I mean, if you're
going to go surfing
you had to lug a 120-pound
board through the sand,
get out there, paddle out.
The thing gets soaked.
You got to bring that back in.
And you're walking around.
And that's a workout.
And you'll see he's
really got a modern body.
I mean, this was probably
taken about 1912, 1915.
And this is what it looks like.
I mean, it was pretty
much you paddled out.
And you came straight in.
And this is shot in
Waikiki, probably
near Diamond Head area.
And we know today
about the North Shore.
Those are the big surf
contests in Hawaii and Oahu.
And those are generally
coming up actually--
December, Christmastime.
Nobody could surf the
North Shore back then.
It just wasn't possible with
the equipment, with the boards.
You basically just
went straight.
And Duke comes around.
So we're talking
1900, when he's 10.
America makes Hawaii
a colony of sorts.
However you want to look at it.
It was part of the imperialistic
surge of America in the late
1890's.
The Philippines,
Puerto Rico, Cuba,
America going beyond
the mainland boundaries.
And very specifically strategic,
military looking to Asia,
Pacific Rim and Britain.
So that makes Duke
an American citizen,
which of course changes
the direction of his life.
And one of that direction is
about sports, and organized
sports, and America
having something
called the AAU, which was a way
to organize amateur sports back
then.
That was something that
Duke could participate in.
And just before I leave
this slide and move
on to his swimming career, it's
interesting to note that Duke,
we call him the
father of surfing.
And one of the reasons
we say that is he
and some other mates on
Waikiki formed, basically,
the first surf club, which
was called the Hui Nalu.
And they were, in
a sense, orphans.
Because the main
athletic club at
the time was the
Outrigger Canoe Club.
And the Outrigger Canoe
Club was whites only.
And so Duke and his mates formed
their own more informal club
called the Hui Nalu.
And that became the
basis of-- and they
devised some of-- the
rules that we still
deal with in terms of surfing.
And the Hui Nalu became an area
that Duke could springboard
with when it came to swimming.
Because while in
Hawaii, he maybe
had been known for
his surfing skills.
And basically, at that time,
the only surfing that was done
was in Hawaii.
To get beyond that, he turned
to competitive swimming.
This photo is a historic photo.
Again, one of those moments when
Duke's life changes forever.
This is 1911 in August.
First AAU meet ever in Hawaii.
And it's a swim meet.
And Duke is out in
front by quite a bit.
He sets two world's records
that day in the 50 and the 100.
And as you can
see, it's Honolulu.
It's outdoors.
That's what most of the
swimming events were back then.
It was outdoors.
There were very few pools.
There wasn't the
modern guidelines
that we have today
with its 50 meters
and you know, and
precisely measured.
This is sort of sports just
beginning to get organized.
And Duke, does indeed, set the
records in the 50 and the 100.
What's interesting is that
when the Hawaiian officials
quite proudly send the marks
in to New York, the home
office of the AAU, the
records are rejected.
And they give all sorts
of weak and lame excuses
for why the records
were turned down.
But basically, it was
sort of its Hawaii.
It's so far away.
They have no oversight.
They have no knowledge of Hawaii
and what these athletes can do.
So they reject Duke's
record and records.
And it's interesting to note
that while that was obviously
a setback and Duke was upset
about it, what it did was
it rallied the Hawaiian
community around Duke.
Because they were as
well insulted by that.
And they decided to prove
that Duke could actually
swim that fast, could beat
the best on the mainland.
And he came from a
working-class family.
By this time he had
dropped out of high school.
He was making a living
as a beach boy, what
we would call a beach boy today,
taking tourists out, teaching
them how to swim and
maybe surf lessons
or in an outrigger canoe.
And Hawaii rallied
around Duke and paid
for him to come to
the mainland in 1912
to try to qualify for
the US Olympic team that
was going to Sweden, to
Stockholm, to compete
at the 1912 Olympics.
So here's Duke.
You know, his first
presence on the mainland.
And as you can see, those
are the competitive swimsuits
of the day.
They were heavy, heavy cotton.
If they were lucky
they were silk.
But they were heavy cotton.
Men had to wear, like, almost
like a codpiece-type thing.
And if you think
that's restrictive,
you should have seen what
the women had to wear.
But they were very,
very elaborate contests.
This is the end of the
Victorian prudish era.
But Duke was an anomaly
at this time, in 1912.
Few people had ever
been to Hawaii.
Few people could ever find
it on a map, quite frankly.
And here he is, a
dark-skinned Pacific Islander,
coming to represent the
United States at the Olympics.
And that was a
little bit different.
Maybe there were some Native
Americans-- most prominently,
Jim Thorpe on the team--
but it was pretty much
a white-only team
in the Olympics
at that time for America.
And here's Duke, with the entire
US Olympic swim team for 1912.
And if you think
about Duke's journey,
he had to take a steamship
from Honolulu to the mainland,
take railroads
across the country,
and then take another ship
from New York to Stockholm
to compete.
And at that time--
just as a side note--
you can see there's,
what, seven men?
And the head of the amateur
AAU was James Sullivan.
He was not a big proponent
of women in sports.
And so this was
the first Olympics
that women swimmers
were competing.
But James Sullivan refused
to allow the Americans
to field a women's team.
So it was just the men.
And Duke, quite
frankly, is great.
You see him here in the middle.
This is all outdoors.
So you know, it's quite frigid
conditions in Stockholm,
though apparently the weather
was actually quite nice.
So they got lucky.
But Duke smashed records.
He won the 100 in quite
controversial fashion.
So there were a lot of
headlines about was he
going to make the finals?
Did he make the finals?
Will he win the gold medal?
Well, he did.
And then they won.
They took the silver
medal in the relay.
And just to point out, there
were just very, very few
swimming events back then.
So we talk about Michael Phelps
winning eight Olympic medals
in the last Olympics.
Well, I don't even think there
were eight swimming events
for the men just by themselves.
There was no Butterfly.
There was no Individual Medley.
There was maybe one
Relay, that sort of thing.
So we're talking the opportunity
was not very vast for him
as a swimmer.
But he made the most of it.
And here he is,
accepting his medal
from the King, King Gustaf.
And like Jim Thorpe,
Duke Kahanamoku
returns to America
a star, a celebrity.
Here he is marching,
parading in New York City,
with the Olympic team.
And by the way, that's
a camera that he's
holding in his left hand.
That's those big, clunky
cameras back then.
He's now famous.
Anywhere he goes
for appearances,
for meets, its headline.
They want to interview him.
And this says, "Kanaka Swimmer
Has No Equal in the Water."
"Kanaka" refers to
Hawaiian native.
It's a little controversial
term in and of itself.
But I mean, there weren't
anybody like Duke.
And so press and media
felt OK to just call him
what they wanted to.
And they would make
up interviews and just
publish it, frankly.
But he's a celebrity.
And people demand
his services to swim.
They want to see him.
This is his trip to
Australia, 1914-1915.
You see that little
speck in the water?
Black, dark speck?
That's Duke surfing.
And the people on
shore are just amazed.
They think this is a
guy walking on water.
There had maybe been not
even a handful of surfers
in Australia.
This is the first celebrity.
And so when he would
come newspapers
would write about him.
He didn't come with
a board, by the way,
when he went to Australia.
He went to swim.
And then he decided-- he saw
the waves-- said, "Hey, I'm
going to surf."
He went to a lumber
yard and shaped a board
and carved it out.
And it was, I think, some
pine wood in Australia.
And then he would
leave it behind.
And in a sense, he was sort
of the Johnny Appleseed
of surfing.
He would leave a board.
That would become the model.
And people would, "Oh, yeah.
Let's do that shape." and he was
very happy to leave that alone.
And you can see, here
he is in the middle.
This is the crowds
that he would draw.
He went there in the winter.
Of course, our winter,
Australia's summer.
And so everybody just would
mob to come out to see him.
And he toured.
He would compete in San
Francisco, at the Sutro Baths.
He would come down here
to Southern California.
He started surfing in Corona Del
Mar, Long Beach, the South Bay.
Those were the big, big
surf areas back then.
And Corona Del Mar,
being the jewel.
And we'll see a little
bit more of that later.
But he's starting to establish
an international reputation.
And he's starting
to make friends
in Southern California and
Los Angeles, especially people
at the Los Angeles
Athletic Club.
And again, that will play
out later in his life.
One of his trips to
Southern California,
he was in Hollywood.
He was put in a movie.
And you can see the
gentleman on Duke's left
was Hobart Bosworth, a
famous producer/director
at the time, a buddy
of Jack London.
And he brought Duke in and
made a little two reeler.
These are all silent
movies, of course.
And just to point out,
you can see Duke's body.
I mean, that's a
modern-day body.
And most of his opponents, quite
frankly, did not have that.
This is again, he
wasn't natural.
He trained.
He was a competitor.
And by the way, that movie
is lost, unfortunately,
like a lot of the
silent movies of today.
When he would go
to the mainland--
and this was shot in
Chicago-- he often
was backed by the
Hawaii promotion outfit.
And Duke would be,
"Hey, play a ditty.
Play a song."
He would do that.
It would help promote Hawaii,
which the business interests
were very, very keen on.
And Duke-- through his
sports, through surfing
and through swimming-- he was
helping to promote Hawaii.
And again, this will be
part of a theme in his life,
that he becomes so connected
to his homeland, to Hawaii.
And he was, of course,
very proud of that.
I should point out
in 1916, again,
when we talk about oh, he
won five Olympic medals.
That's a lot.
But, you know, Michael Phelps
did that in one Olympics.
But the Olympics of 1916
were cancelled, of course,
for World War I. They were
supposed to be in Berlin.
And so Duke, in the prime
of his athletic life,
was not able to defend
his crown in 1916.
But he decides to stay
on and stay an amateur
and that's no easy
feat back then.
Because there
weren't endorsements.
You weren't allowed
to take an endorsement
if you were an amateur athlete.
So Duke did make it
to the 1920 Olympics.
This is him on the far
right, with his teammates,
many of whom were Hawaiian.
And Duke, again, just--
not shocks the world.
By then he's the
defending champ--
but he's also 30
years old, which
is quite ancient for
swimmers, even today.
And Duke defends his title
in the 100 and wins the gold,
wins the relay as well,
sort of adding to his fame.
And having skipped 1916
Olympics from 1912 to 1920,
it's a pretty incredible feat.
And here you can see
this is the Relay team.
The Olympics of 1920
were in Antwerp.
It was sort of a
last-minute thing.
The Pierre de Coubertin, the
head of the IOC at the time,
wanted to get the Olympics get
back going after World War I.
And so the Olympics
were in Antwerp.
And frankly, they were a
war-torn country at that time
and weren't really prepared.
And the conditions
were just abysmal,
including the pool, absolutely
frigid temperatures.
And you can see
them, the guys just
sort of huddling to stay warm.
And as I said, Duke's
Relay team wins the gold.
So he adds two gold medals.
I do point out that the
competition wasn't that great
in 1920 because of the damage
of the war, unfortunately.
Germany was not
allowed to compete.
Russia was not allowed
to compete in 1920.
And frankly, a lot of the
competitors from Australia,
the young men from
Australia, many
had died or been
wounded in the war.
So the competition level
was a little less in 1920.
But Duke was there.
And he trained and won the gold.
And just so you can
see what the start
line looks like in 1920,
outdoors, masses of people
around.
After the Olympics, Duke
returns briefly to Hawaii.
But he comes to Southern
California for the first time
for an extended stay in 1922.
And he's brought here by
a promoter specifically
to be a Hollywood star.
And these are one of
the promotion pictures.
I believe this is Venice Beach.
And you know, Duke, of course,
shooting a few golf balls
while his promoter
handler has the surfboard
in the background.
And the initial
plans fell through.
And Duke was not a star.
And as you'll see-- and I'll
get to this a little bit
later-- he did run across,
of course, Hollywood.
The racism of
Hollywood at the time,
and certainly, no leading
man could be a non-white,
to get the girl and so on.
So Duke has a good time, though.
He surfs in Southern
California as you can see.
Up and down.
That's I think, Corona
del Mar, Venice.
That was on the cover of
"The Los Angeles Times"
Sunday magazine.
And again, a little bit
risque in the sense of you
have a dark-skinned man
and the woman is actually
the wife of his coach.
And Duke joins the Los
Angeles Athletic Club.
And you can see their logo.
That's one of the
Olympic swimmers.
By now, James Sullivan has died.
So women can now compete
for America in the Olympics.
And they do quite well in
diving and in swimming.
That's Mickey Riley,
another great diver.
And Duke's wearing
a beard there.
He gets, basically, to
be an extra in the films.
And I'll show you some
other slides of that.
But that logo on his
waist, or around his thigh
there, that's still the
mercury logo of the Los Angeles
Athletic Club.
And that became the
basis of his life
both in terms of athletics
and swimming competition,
but also social
life and so forth.
A lot of Hollywood stars
were part of the Los Angeles
Athletic Club
And he stays in training.
Because the Hollywood
thing didn't really
pan out in 1922, '23, he
decides to go for the Olympics
in 1924, which were in Paris.
This is a beautiful
outdoor stadium.
It was the first pool that was
50 meters for the Olympics,
I believe, or at
least built that way.
But now Duke is 34 years old.
Again, now beyond ancient
for swimming, and especially
sprints.
And so there's some
major competition,
including his younger brother.
Duke had about six,
seven siblings.
This is Sam Kahanamoku.
Smaller, but had
emerged in the early 20s
as the top sprinter in Hawaii.
So Duke is competing
against his younger brother.
And he's also
competing against a guy
who would become his arch
rival in this time span.
And this is, of course,
Johnny Weissmuller.
And the logo, it's
Illinois Athletic Club.
They were out of Chicago.
And that was a hotbed
of competitive swimming.
And Johnny was, in some
ways, very similar to Duke.
He was working class stock.
He was a high school drop out.
In some ways, they
were very similar.
He was also an amazing swimmer.
And he is 21, 22 years old here.
Duke is 34.
And they don't meet.
The newspapers sort of
build up this rivalry.
They don't meet until the
Olympic trials of 1924.
And then they meet
again in the Olympics.
And spoiler alert, we'll tell
you what happens on that.
And so here is the
Olympic team for 1924,
for the United States,
as you can see in there.
This is the Hawaiian
contingent, as you can see.
There's now women on the
team, and Duke and his younger
brother.
And this is the finals.
And Duke and Johnny head to
head and Johnny is on the right
there in the middle of
the frame of the photo.
And Johnny wins the gold medal.
Duke takes silver.
But this is now the '20s,
we're talking the Roaring '20s.
And whereas Duke was a
big star, a major star,
Johnny turns out
to be a megastar.
I mean, you've got
the '20s of Babe Ruth.
You've got Jack Dempsey.
You've got sports stars
becoming bigger than life.
And Johnny takes advantage
of that, as we'll see.
And Duke was
friends with Johnny.
They were rivals of course, but
was friends, even afterwards,
as we'll see, as well, later.
But obviously it was
a disappointment.
This was going to be
perhaps his swan song
for Duke at the Olympics.
And only get second.
And his younger brother,
Sam, got the bronze medal.
So Duke retreated to Hollywood,
or Southern California.
And he did pursue a career.
He signed with Paramount.
And here he is in "Lord Jim."
And he's helping to teach one
of the actresses how to swim.
Here he is in "The
Pony Express,"
playing a Native American
Indian, of course.
He was actually a
good horseback rider.
This is "Hula," which
is one of the few
that were actually having
a Hawaiian theme in it.
And the actress that
he's playing with
is Clara Bow, who
was known as the "It"
girl, was the big
star of Hollywood
back in the early '20s.
But I think you can sort of
see a theme emerging, which
is to say, Duke was not a star.
He was an extra.
And he was playing these
character roles, what
we would call ethnic roles.
And that was an
unfortunately the extent.
And he appeared in a
couple dozen movies,
but never got really
the big, big star.
And most of these were silent.
Some of these are lost today.
We don't have access to them.
But some of it, like "Hula,"
we have a full version of.
Which it's a pretty amazing
little movie, actually.
Here he is, playing
a Barbary pirate,
getting strangled
by Wallace Beery.
And there's the glamour shot.
And again, as you can tell, he's
playing a tribesmen of sorts.
And unfortunately
that was about as far
as he could go in Hollywood.
And this is probably about 1925,
'26, '27, around that time.
He still keeps surfing.
He teaches some of the
Hollywood community how to surf.
He's one of the first
surfers to surf in Malibu
and starts extending
surfing as surfing
becomes sort of beyond
Hawaii and coming
to Southern California.
And this was probably
taken in Corona del Mar,
down in Orange County,
which was the primo surf
spot, as I mentioned.
And you can see that board
is just whatever, 12 feet, 16
feet.
And he would retreat here with
buddies from the Los Angeles
Athletic Club.
And it was at Corona
del Mar in 1925
that Duke made national
headlines again.
And when I was
researching this book
I kept running across references
of Duke rescuing people
swimming.
And this was in Hawaii.
This was on the mainland.
And it was sort of part and
parcel of being a waterman.
You would notice people
who didn't swim very well.
And quite frankly,
in those days,
they didn't have a lot
of swimming instruction
and fins to learn on as a kid.
So there were many accidents
back in that day of drowning
and so forth.
So I kept running across
this, Duke rescuing people,
would-be drowning victims.
And it all came to fruition
in 1925 in Corona del Mar.
And these are his buddies, a
couple buddies from the Los
Angeles Athletic Club.
And what happened that day,
it was a fishing vessel.
A recreational fishing vessel
went out with a bunch of guys
from Riverside, California.
They were going to
fish for abalone.
And they were trying to
get out of the harbor.
And they got smashed
by a groundswell.
And a couple just
rogue waves just
slammed into the
boat, The Thelma,
and it capsized and overturned.
And Duke, as you can see
with this surf board,
saw what was happening.
They were just down to surf.
He ran out into the
surf, paddled out,
threw three guys-- drowning
victims-- on his surfboard.
Paddled in, deposited them
on the beach to his buddies.
Went out again, got three more.
Paddled in, did
it one more time.
And he was credited later--
overall-- with rescuing
eight people.
And never got, really thank
you'd for it by the people
at that time, though he got
some medals from the Los Angeles
Athletic Club.
But it was one of
those episodes, again,
he made national headlines.
But it was also important
because people realized
the importance of a surfboard.
It wasn't just about recreation.
You know?
It was a life-saving
device, perhaps.
It was something
beyond just, OK we're
going to have fun in the waves.
So it established
that tradition.
By now, Duke is late 30s.
The Hollywood career,
not working out so well.
He retreats to
Hawaii for a while
and tries to figure
out what's next.
He had never really taken a job.
He got some crappy jobs.
He was, like, a janitor.
People were
horrified to discover
he was mowing the lawn
of City Hall in Honolulu.
And he's just trying to
figure out what is next.
And frankly, Los Angeles called.
And 1932 is Los
Angeles Olympics.
And the Olympic
games of '32 in LA
were pretty much spearheaded by
the Los Angeles Athletic Club.
So they basically called
Duke and said, hey,
do you want to give
it one more time?
And he's now,
basically, 40 years old.
But he loves LA.
Olympic games of '32,
this is the first time
since the games of 1904 that
the Olympics are in what
they would call the new world.
And 1904 games, nobody
even noticed them.
So this was a big deal.
So he said, you know what?
I'm going to try for it.
See what happens.
And as you can see, the
games, this was the building.
They built the Colosseum in
the '20s to bid for the games.
And obviously the
reference today, of course,
LA looking for the 2024 bid.
But they certainly had the
wherewithal to build it.
And Curtis, by the way, that
headline is the Vice President.
Herbert Hoover
decided not to show up
for the opening ceremonies.
This is during, of
course, the Depression.
And here's Duke.
He's on the far left there,
with Johnny Weissmuller
in the middle.
And the fellow next
to him is a guy
named Buster Crabbe,
who you guys may
know as a great swimmer and
also, of course, as an actor.
But Duke is not able to
make the team in 1932.
Other people have written
that he did make the team
and I think we try to
debunk that in the book,
as we try to debunk a few myths
that have arisen around Duke.
And this is one of them.
But he fails to make
the team, frankly.
And the gentleman
who does succeed--
and he's finishing up
here-- is Buster Crabbe.
And Buster is the American
male to win a gold medal.
Actually, it's the
Japanese swimmers
are the dominant
swimmers in 1932, 1936.
But Buster Crabbe,
by being in LA
and winning and
being who he is, he's
a great-looking guy
and very charismatic.
Of course, Buster
Crabbe, as we know,
went on to a huge
Hollywood career.
And of course, so did
Duke's earlier rival,
which was Johnny Weissmuller.
And this comes out
right around the time
of the 1932 Olympic games.
And of course, Johnny
Weissmuller as "Tarzan."
It was perfect for him.
He could wear a loin cloth.
He didn't have to say very
much except grunt a little bit
and play with the monkey.
And it must have been
a little disappointing.
Duke was a very taciturn guy.
He didn't talk about his
emotions and disappointments.
But this was probably
certainly one of them.
And he pretty much retreated
to Hawaii after this.
He left LA around 1930,
came back for the '32 games,
moved back to Hawaii.
These are two of his
brothers, Sargent and Sam.
And basically, he
travels quite a bit.
But he spends most of the
rest of his life in Hawaii,
back in his homeland.
And tries to figure
out what's next.
What does a high
school dropout do?
And he is persuaded to run
for Sheriff of Honolulu.
And it's sort of
patronage type job.
But it's also an elected office.
And he runs and wins
every other year.
And that becomes his job.
He follows from his
father who is the police
Sergeant in law enforcement.
And he holds that job
from, basically, mid
to late '30s all the way
up to 1959 when, of course,
Hawaii becomes the 50th state.
He also has a sideline,
which is to say-- you see him
in the back of the Outrigger,
Diamond Head in the distance--
you know, he's now as big a
celebrity as pretty much every
sports star.
And so when important
people come to Hawaii
in the '30s-- and tourism is
now starting to really boom
in Hawaii, of course.
Because transportation's
a little bit easier.
People have some money after
the Depression-- and so the rich
and the famous come.
And they are often are steered
to Duke for entertainment,
to go out in an outrigger,
and to just hobnob with Duke
Kahanamoku.
So of course, there's
Babe Ruth, who
was en route or coming
back from Japan to do
an exhibition in the '30s.
And Amelia Earhart, of course,
before her plane crash.
And if necessary, he would
indulge in a little Hula
if the spirit moved him.
And he was a great,
great dancer, apparently.
And one of the controversial
aspects of his life
that had really never been
brought out before certainly
about him outside
of the sports realm
was one of the famous people
who came to Hawaii in the '30s.
And that's Doris
Duke, who, as you see,
is in the middle with
Duke and his brothers.
And Doris Duke, for those
who don't know that name,
her family is Duke University.
It was the tobacco fortune.
And her parents died
when she was very young.
She was the richest
little girl in the world.
And she came to
Hawaii for a honeymoon
and loved Hawaii, loved
the Kahanamoku brothers.
And that's Sam Kahanamoku
and Doris Duke.
And again, she's
a married woman.
And so there have
been reports of did
she have an affair with Sam?
Did she have an
affair with Duke?
She had a child who was born
who lived for a couple days
and then passed away.
And nobody is sure
who the father was.
And there's been rumors
that it was Duke or Sam.
So that was a bit of a mystery.
In this time, Duke
marries in 1940,
to Nadine Alexander,
or Nah-dean Alexander,
as she would pronounce it.
And she was a Haole
woman-- a white woman--
from the mainland.
She was a ballroom
dancer/instructor.
And by all accounts, quite
a bit of an age difference.
By all accounts, very different,
but enjoyed a long marriage.
And Duke was married to her
for the rest of his life.
And so he's now settled.
We're talking 1940.
He's ensconced as the
Sheriff of Honolulu.
He's married.
And of course, all that gets
disrupted by Pearl Harbor
in 1941.
Duke is part of
the law enforcement
but not a big part
of the war effort.
But it does, of course, change
again, the direction of Hawaii
and where it's going.
Duke remains--
during this time--
still sort of a celebrity.
I mean, he comes to the
mainland to Santa Cruz to surf,
to bring a team.
This is Southern California.
And this was taken by
a famous early surf
photographer, Doc Ball.
And this is Duke in
Orange County, like, 1949.
And it's interesting.
Because he gets embraced
by the surf community.
The Olympic committee's there.
But the Olympics are
every four years.
The surfing's going nuts.
And surfing is really
starting to grow
in the post-war
America, and especially
on the mainland,
Southern California
starting to rival Hawaii as
the epicenter of surfing.
And Duke is seen as sort of
the godfather of surfing.
He's the connection
between ancient surf
riding and the modern era.
And they're starting to
move away from wood boards.
They're going to the
more modern boards.
And Duke has a surf team.
He gets backed by a promoter.
And they have a Duke
Kahanamoku invitational.
I'm skipping ahead a little bit.
But this is North Shore.
I mean, because now, even
though those boards are
pretty big by today's
standards, they
are a lot more maneuverable.
They've got fins
and people have been
starting to surf the North Shore
starting from the late '50s.
So that becomes the
epicenter of surfing
in Hawaii, the North Shore.
And these are three
of those gentlemen
are still alive today.
I interviewed all three
of them for the book.
And they're all in the
surfing hall of fame.
He opened up his club, the
Duke Kahanamoku's Club.
His big act-- who he
helped make a huge star--
was, of course, Don Ho.
So Don Ho broke big there.
And of course, you know
the restaurants today,
Duke's, like in Malibu,
and also in Hawaii,
and in Orange County, they're
not connected with that Duke
Kahanamoku's.
But it was that initial idea.
And in a sense, Duke was
one of the first athletes
to be branded, what we
would call branded today.
And it was about creating
surfboards and a club
and that sort of thing.
He was still trotted
out when need be,
when President John
F. Kennedy came.
I tried really hard to
make a connection with Duke
and President Obama
because, of course,
President Obama was
born in '61 in Hawaii.
And I tried.
I'm not sure how
successful I was.
But I'm hoping he
reads the book and lets
me know if there's any anecdotes
for the paperback edition.
And he's honored.
I mean, now he's an older man.
He's in his late 70s.
He's there at the Swimming Hall
of Fame, Johnny Weissmuller,
Buster Crabbe.
But like I said, he's
really more connected
with the surf community.
For various reasons, in
part by the promotion.
And in part, because surfing
gets really super sexy
in the '60s.
You've got Gidget.
You've got the Beach Boys,
Dick Dale, that sort of thing.
Duke's health starts
failing in the late '60s.
He has some illnesses
and ailments.
He's looking a
little bit old there.
He dies in 1968, which
was the same year--
people have pointed out--
as "Hawaii Five-0"--
the original "Hawaii
Five-0"-- comes on the air.
So there's your life span.
You know, Queen Liliuokalani to
"Hawaii Five-0" and "Book 'em,
Danno!"
And his funeral was one of
the biggest beach boy funerals
on the beaches of Waikiki.
And Nadine, his widow,
is in the white.
And that's on the beach.
And they take out his
ashes into the ocean
and sprinkle them, the
traditional beach boy funeral.
So I'll wrap this up and
again, welcome your questions
afterwards.
His legacy, of
course, is extensive.
I mean, they rallied
to do a postage stamp.
He's the godfather of
surfing, so much so
that in 1999, they called him
the surfer of the century.
He hadn't surfed in 50 years.
That's his legacy.
He's the touchstone to the
ancient days of Hawaii,
to those traditions,
to the modern era.
And of course, to today,
turning 125 this summer.
And as you can see,
even Google just
said surfboard,
surfboard, surfboard.
And as well it should.
Because that's what we'll know.
But I mentioned the branding.
I think that was an
important element.
And I do also want to point
out-- as I've talked about,
touched on during this talk--
his role as a racial pioneer.
And I think that
was been ignored.
People talk about Jesse Owens
and Joe Louis and Jack Johnson
and well and good
heroes and pioneers.
And I think sometimes Duke
has been lost in that shuffle.
And I hope this book
brings that out.
So thank you for your attention.
And thanks for coming.
And I would love to
welcome your questions.
AUDIENCE: So I've been to
the Outrigger Canoe Club.
And there's a
plaque on the wall.
And it says that
he was a member.
So I guess maybe later
they made him a member?
DAVID DAVIS: Correct.
Correct.
They were shamed into it.
But after his Olympic heroics,
and after he was supported
and his nickname was
the Ambassador of Aloha.
And there's still a
big statue of Duke
on the beach in Waikiki.
Once that happened, once
they, the business interests,
realized that he was an asset to
Hawaii and to promoting Hawaii,
yeah.
They brought him into the fold.
And it's controversial to
this day, a little bit.
Because when his widow
passed away some years
after his death, the legacy
of his name and likeness
went to a nonprofit, but
controlled by the Outrigger.
And a lot of Hawaiians
were upset about that.
Because it was
usurping the name,
the Kahanamoku name,
under the Outrigger,
which had turned him away.
But yes, he was a member
starting from the late teens,
and then for the
rest of his life.
And he made that one of
his one of his locales.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
DAVID DAVIS: Thank you, yeah.
AUDIENCE: You alluded
to some controversy
about his first Olympics.
Can you say something
else about that?
DAVID DAVIS: Sure.
In 1912, in Stockholm--
so the 100 meters,
I guess there were three
Americans competing
to make it to the finals.
And they came out after
winning the quarter finals.
And they were told
by their coaches,
oh, the semifinals
are the next day.
So they all retreated
to the ship.
That was the athletes'
village back then
for the American team.
The athletes slept on the ship.
They didn't realize, or they
got the wrong information.
And the semi's were that night.
And the three
Americans missed it.
They missed the race.
Technically, they should
have been disqualified.
And there were several
countries, athletes
who said, hey, they're done.
Apparently some of the
Australian contingent athletes
said, hey, that's unfair.
This is 1912.
Hey, that's unfair.
That's not good sportsmanship.
You can't penalize them for
just missing a start time.
So the swimming powers
that be met and came up
with a compromise, which was
they got another heat to race.
And Duke was able to win
and qualify for the finals.
And then in the finals, he wins.
But this was over several days.
And so when you read the
newspapers from back then,
the headlines are
"Kahanamoku misses
race," or "Disqualified."
And so it took days before
they could figure this out
in Hawaii.
And remember, back then
it's telegraph and so forth,
communication wise.
It's not quite the
Google aspect of things.
So there was a lot
of controversy.
And that gentleman
who spearheaded
the Australian contingent
saying, hey, let Duke race
was a guy named Cedric Healy.
And Duke beat him.
Cedric Healy got
the silver medal.
So his good sportsmanship
maybe cost him a gold.
And unfortunately,
just on a postscript,
Cedric Healy was killed at
Gallipoli in 1915 or 1916.
But yeah, that was
the controversy.
[APPLAUSE]